Don't you know Han's a doxer? Oh my god. We already had this
argument. Everybody already had this argument and they all understood
and agreed that it was
his name is in state only. Not even city. That's not doxing.
No, it's not doxing. Forgotten Jones. If if my name is Mike from
PA and you say you're Mike from PA, are you doxing me? No, bro.
His username is a shorter version of his last name. Yes. Hutch
is being a useful idiot for People want him to freak out. He's
being used and made to freak out by people who he should be able
to trust. And he is making a complete ass of himself repeatedly.
These people do not have his best interest at heart. He's being
told, "Yeah, you were doxed by Hassan." And he's not stopping
to think about it. He's just like the golem. He's just moving
forward. He's got his commands. Destroy Hassan. That's his only
goal right now. And it doesn't matter what he does to his own
credibility to do it. He's going to destroy it. Okay? He's going
to destroy Hassan. He's going to destroy himself. Himself. Himself.
Himself.
We're done with this one. All right. So, he talked about that.
Talked about lowering the temperature. All of this. Okay. We're
moving forward to
not only was he doing these baseless accus We're moving to Hassan
doxed me and several other creators. Hutch video from five days
ago. All right. Hassan doxed me and several other creators. I
do look forward to seeing how he makes the argument that he was
doxed.
I actually don't know. And also I guess I would like to see maybe
he just has son's camera up the whole time. How he prevents any.
>> He doxed us. He doxed. It's like prominently featured
on his screen. I don't know what to say, man. I mean, like, I
reported the VOD. I reported the VOD. I sent an email to like
Twitch support. Like, if he if if there's no consequence for
this, like I don't know what are there just like there's just
no rules. Like, I don't understand. It is a blatant violation
of Twitch's doxing policy. And I think it kind of reveals like
what an actual piece of he is. He was so happy to use that empanada
as his >> Oh god, he's going to use like the legal mindset
video, isn't he? Uh, I don't know if I need to watch this whole
thing. I'm going to leave you guys to watch for a second. I'll
be back. >> And then he got tired of Bad Empanada nipping
at his heels. And so now he now you ban Bad Empanada because
you're getting harassed. >> So over the weekend, I was
going pretty hard in the paint for the chorus story from Taylor
Lorent. like the whole thing just really me off and I
started to notice like a lot of a lot like more than usual comments
uh that were totally and completely unhinged.
>> I started seeing people saying like, "Oh, did it did
it feel good to take that blood money from that?" And I'm like,
"I don't even [__] I don't know what we're talking
about here. It could be like 10 different things to these psychos."
And then I tried to get clarity from from some people and and
and nobody wanted to like they they kept on linking this one
picture of an FEC filing
from last July and it was a onetime payment of $2,000
and it represented work that I did with a pack called Victory
uh Progressive Victory Pack. Um,
I I didn't know this at the time, but I think Progressive Victory
Pack, a lot of that early kind of support came from uh Vos's
community. I would have to look at the website as to like what
their mission statement is, but I think it's generally to promote
progressive politics and progressive politicians all over the
>> Is he pretending he just heard of Did he just hear of
Progressive Vic? Oh my god. Now, I just figured out who progressive
victory is, guys. But don't worry, the proof that I disclosed
it is the Nightbot command. Okay, I can't even say the name of
the pack that paid me. I can't remember it, but apparently I've
disclosed it enough that that's perfect. Okay, this is no problems,
guys. No problems at all.
>> With the country. >> Uh, but it's not just limited
to progressive politicians. So, they did a canvasing event for
Jamal Bowman, who's pretty progressive. Uh, he was serving at
the time and he was looking >> They did a different group
did it. a different like group of influencers went >> to
defend a seat. I think he lost that primary. They did a canvasing
event for Andy Kim. They did a canvasing event for Kla Harris.
But during 2024, I think the pack was just it was all about just,
you know, basically like helping
uh do better in the country. I think they still have a public
website that anybody can go to and and find out what what what
they're all about. So, uh we've talked about this a bunch.
Um, for my part, whenever I did any kind of like there's a there's
a nightbot command right there if you type exclamation mark TV
much has partnered with progressive victory. Progressive victory
is an online community of volunteers, activists, and organizers.
Using the power of the internet, we're winning elections, protecting
democracy, and building the next generation of organizers. Get
involved here. Progressive victory.win. I find this interesting
because it is not ah
I would like for it to say sponsored partnered with like sponsored
by has been sponsored by partnered with might just mean I believe
in this and I'm driving engagement to it out of the goodness
of my heart. There's a big difference between this and disclosing
a paid monetary sponsorship >> in Twitch. For my part,
whenever I did any kind of segment that was coordinated
>> progressive victory, I would have that nightbot command
play or I would, you know, have the nightbot command show up
in the chat and then um I would uh tell my chat like I'm doing
paid work with progressive victory. Like I was not >> Okay,
he was telling his chat he did paid work. Okay. >> Trying
to hide it. Um, I I I don't know what I put in my Twitter bio,
but I think it was something like partnered with Progressive
Victory or whatever. So, like I tend to overdisclose for these
kinds of things. I think that's like generally a best practice
that creators should do. Pretty topical for the last week of
discourse, but there's really no harm in like overdisclosing
unless you're violating an NDA or something like that. I I just
have to point out. Okay, so like if progressive victory was paying
creators to do Israeli propelling,
go ahead and say exactly what Hutch is saying. What do you think
Hutch is saying right now? I feel like Hutch what Hutch is saying
here is reasonable. Y'all are just hating. Go ahead and tell
me what Hutch is saying. I'm not hitting play on the video until
you actually summize what he's been saying for the past 5 minutes.
He did pay work. He did pay work. And not that that can't be
it. You can't just say he did pay work. There's got to be a little
more there, right? I I think he did pay work. I'm waiting. I'm
waiting because obviously I'd need more than one statement of
like, I told my chat that I was paid by Progressive Victory.
I'd need more than just that statement to actually talk about
what he's saying. He just said he did paid work for PV.
Okay. What is his overall message that he's disclosed it more
than enough, right? He's also said only one month. I don't know
if that's true. I would love to know if he was only paid one
month. Maybe he was only paid one month. But the entire thing
is about disclosing a paid sponsorship, right? Maybe he did say
he disclosed a paid sponsorship and then I said that. So I don't
know why you're freaking out. I said, "Oh, he let his chat know."
He said a one. No, he said what? What happened was they disclosed
a onetime $2,000 payment. So I'm not totally sure. >> Propaganda.
How do you explain this? This is a canvasing event
that Progressive Victory organized to support Jamal Bowman. Okay,
how does that make sense? So right away
this theory nonsense. Okay. >> Yeah. I would say progressive
victory was not operating purely with the the destiny camp in
mind. There was a group of influencers like Vosch and like more
more like lefty progressives who did go out and campus for Jamal
Bowman. That was uh progressive brat riverboat jackos
and who's the tro person? Nominal Naomi. There's a couple other
people there too. Oh, Matt Matt Binder was there. Although I
don't know if Matt Binder was there, too, though. Okay. It was
like that group. That's a totally different group than the group
that Hutch was usually I would argue like a part Sorry. That's
a totally different group than the one Hutch was like a part
of and associated with. So, yeah. I don't know. I don't know,
man. I feel like saying, "Oh, well, Jamal, dude, there's no way
you could call it Okay, I actually do agree that you shouldn't
call it a Zionist slush fund or something like that, right? You'd
have to be pretty specific. But I would say the people they paid
I would say there's parts of that that it's like there was a
group that were the liberal group that was kind of just like
Destiny and Friends. That's like I think that's accurate to say.
Now is that like the entire core of progressive victory and everything
they're about? No. Why did they canvas for Bowman? Because the
progressive group that was with Vosch and Riverbo Jack and the
far leftists like Jamal Bowman as a candidate and there are progressive
people in the like higher structure of progressive victory who
like those kinds of candidates. But through Bon Banna Woo, they
started, you know, they started talking to Destiny. They started
trying to get the more liberal part involved. And that liberal
part that Hutch was involved with all had very similar opinions
and canvas for liberal candidates, right? I think I think if
I remember correctly, there were a lot of r/ Destiny posts about
this canvasing event that people were that Progressive Victory
was using, you know, Destiny's influence to go and canvas for
Jamal Bowman,
right? Like Destiny's part of that organization, Destiny's community
was attacking the organization for doing this from what I remember.
Rubbo Jackson's streamer. So all that to say, right, the Destiny
and Friends thing is pretty separate from the Jamal Bowman part
of the group. And I think ah man, I'm trying to think of if there's
a better way to differentiate. You don't just say the the Destiny
thing. Also, I just realized I haven't shilled at all, guys.
We're nine subs away from two more hours in the stream. Haven't
chilled yet, guys. Get your subs in. Okay, you can sub on kick.
can donate through TTS. Exclamation boy, donate the chat. We'll
give you the TTS links. I'll pin one of those. I'll pin Streamlabs.
Okay, you can donate through Streamlabs. You can donate through
Kickbot.
Uh nine subs away. I'm probably if we if we don't hit it, I might
cut out, but I'll probably try to finish some more of the Hut
stuff. So anyway, I just think this idea that like oh well they
this group uh canvas this group that was here before us that
wasn't the Briana Woo like recruited part, they canvased for
Jamal Bowman. Therefore, all of your all of your criticisms or
disagreements are invalid. Maybe you could argue that like trying
to argue it's a Zionist slush fund is invalid. Yeah, you could
probably argue that. I would agree with that though. I think
most of the thoughts of Progressive Victory being Zionist is
just downstream of Destiny and Friends being one of the groups.
That's it. >> I was going to get into this a little bit
later. I was going to reference this, but right away the the
whole conspiracy theory, it's gone. gone. There's nothing that
you can say to reconcile a canvasing event for Jamal Bowman,
who is super outspoken critic of Israel with the allegation that
Pave was doing Israeli propaganda. You cannot
reconcile these things. Uh Pave also put on an event that uh
Emma Vigeland was at. Emma Vigland, I think, shared a panel.
It was her and Vos
and Destiny. They those three they did a panel together. So it
was Emma Viglin on the T >> and then Destiny went home
and spurred the out about them and totally blew up what was supposed
to be like crosspollination between these groups. They're supposed
to cross-pollinate the groups, right? And they just didn't after
because Destiny came in and he like flipped the table over and
was like, "These people are scum. I hate these people so much."
Because Vosch is way more of a social butterfly than Destiny.
And he was embarrassed that Vos could go and talk to people and
Destiny is like an child who wanted to play with his game boy
in a corner. Okay, that's what happened. And then a bunch of
us, including me, I was like, "Wow, Vos is like a social guy.
I thought he's going to be a he's way more social than Destiny."
And Destiny was like, "You think he's more social than me? [__]
you." And then he blew it all up, right? >> Take Now I'm
not saying she was paid for that, but but she was >> she
showed up for that event, I think.
Yes, frugals. He basically was like, "If Vos will apologize to
me." By the way, I don't think he asked for like Well, I don't
know if he asked for like an official public Keels apology, which
I think Keffles did way more to ruin his reputation than Bosch
did. Which kind of which kind of gives you like an insight into
what was going on there. Apparently, Keffels did approach him
to give him a private apology. But to me, it's like you're the
guy who says apologies don't matter. Just change your behavior.
You got a private apology from her. She totally destroyed you
publicly, right? She totally [__] with your opinion
public or sorry your reputation publicly. You didn't demand a
public apology from her, but you want one from
>> I'm pretty sure that panel was put on in an official
capacity with progressive victory. I could be wrong, but I'm
pretty sure that was what was happening there. Okay, you can
still find a VOD of that panel of them of them three talking.
Okay, Pokemon and Valkyrie.
>> Who did they who did they hire after that Hutch? How
did their hiring shift after that panel would be the question
to ask the operative question here? >> That's true. They
did some kind of an event where they had an they had a conversation
with Bernie Sanders. This was facilitated by Progressive Victory.
So, I guess Pokemon and Valkyrie are like secret Zionist shills
or something like that. I don't know. It's ridiculous. But the
point the point is, guys, is that there was never any substance
ever to this allegation that Progressive Victory was doing Zionist
>> Yeah, I don't really think that's true. I think I understand
why people connect that, but they connect everything to Zionist
propaganda. So, it's just stupid. Like you you want to you want
to turn everything you want to make all of your content about
Israel Palestine. So, you find things that could possibly be
Zionist propaganda that you think you could connect and you just
try to force the connection. It's like what they do broadly.
It wasn't based on anything.
Literally nothing. There's nothing. >> Why does he keep
Why does he have to push? It's based on something. It's just
based on something you can't make the connection on,
right? It's like saying Destiny's uh what do you call it? It's
like it's like an important distinction. I'm not going to say
it's like okay to make that comparison cuz it's not, right? Especially
when you advocate for like oh, we should be able to dox and harass
any Zionist, you know, propagandists, right? So, are you Yeah,
sure, Cam. But it's it has some basis, right? Like I understand
the basis. I understand how somebody could try to twist that
narrative, but it's it's wrong. It's just totally wrong.
That you can point to to even begin to justify such an outrageous
claim.
There's nothing, literally nothing. It all came from this person
right here. That's where the whole thing started. This guy right
here, this creator right here, you guys, that's the other thing,
too. Lykan and Straighter Aid, they were both in uh involved
with Progressive Victory. I don't know if they strike you guys
as super pro-Israel.
I don't get that vibe. So, if Progressive Victory was hiring
people to do Zionist propaganda, why the did they bring those
two on? By the way, those were not the only two super progressive
people
in that pool of creators that was doing work with PB. Thankfully
for me,
Progressive Victory did not get my correct address, which is
like pretty lucky. So, you know, get nerds. But so, this guy
finds the this guy finds the thing.
>> Okay. And then he makes a video that Hassan in this
video here from seven days ago. So, last last Wednesday, Hassan
on his stream was >> I mean, that's a fair question, I
suppose, Ry. I suppose that's a fair question, but I don't I
don't think Hutch is like actively associating with Destiny,
but there's just like a lot of some funny stuff going on here.
>> Watching a video from Bad Empanada.
>> Uh the name of the video is like all these slaptubers
are paid Zionist shills or something like that. And then, you
know, so I I find this video last night. I don't know if I was
the first one in the group to find it. I don't know if Lonerbox
found it before I did. Um I'm kind of surprised that it took
me a minute to find this video because >> you guys found
it because the black cap person added all of you on Twitter and
was like, "Don't you know who saw a docer? Oh my god." Just blew
up all of that information. Make sure as many people could see
it as possible. Her and Dan. Awesome duo. Let's go. Get those
doces out there. Get them as visible as possible, guys. Let's
go >> in this video. Uh, bad. >> By the way, that's
a joke. That's sarcasm. Obviously thing to do. Obviously, a thing
that you would do if you only cared about getting Hassan and
didn't care about Hutch or Loner Box or anybody in this video
at all. Sorry. In case I know we have we we struggle with autism
here. I should probably make the sarcasm a little more obvious,
okay, that the only reason you draw attention to any of this,
if it were real doxing, okay, it's not necessarily real doxing
um for all of these people, but if it were, you'd be drawing
attention to all of it. You'd be giving these people's information
away. You'd be like making it as big as possible. Most people
don't like that. Most people not fans.
But what you want to do is you want to get Hassan and you don't
care if you somebody else over to do it. So it is what it is.
Hassan didn't dox. Hassan probably showed doc information like
PII for some people like Dylan Burns. Now
there's an argument here and I I think I'd still say for the
toos I would want Hassan to be timed out or or banned for this
cuz I don't want the plausible deniability thing to be a thing.
But I think I don't know if I'd call it doxing because I think
it's downstream of like a legitimate interest in this information
and trying to tie it into a story he's doing. I think there's
an argument there,
but I I think probably you could just create this argument whenever
you wanted and dox people with impunity if that's what you wanted
to do. Anyone who had public information with their like name
out there, right? You just find a story you wanted to cover that
sort of crosses some adjacent paths and then you figure out how
to get it rolled in. Yeah, exactly. Tequila Sunset. Yeah, that's
the point I was making. I think Dylan probably does have an argument
that he was doxed. >> It shows like partial doces, like
full-on partial doces, the type of personal information that
is not allowed on Twitch as a platform, like you are not allowed
to show that kind of
And Hassan not only
uh echoes and repeats the outrageous claims that Bad Empanada
was making in this video, he expands on them even further and
pauses the video at times where this partial docked information
is like prominently featured on his screen. It blew my mind.
I was watching this video last night and I knew that Hassan was
really bad. Like I knew that he was really bad. I didn't I honestly
like he exceeded my already
low expectations cuz he's watching this video from bad empanada
and he's repeating the claims. He seems to be
>> what? Oh, Han is bad. Han is bad. Hassan is bad. in
this video agreeing with
>> Hassan is bad >> that we at Progressive Victory
were taking money to do Israeli propaganda like he's repeat he
repeats the
>> and seems to legitimize them. I know he's not stupid
enough to actually believe this. Like anybody who's stupid enough
to believe that conspiracy theory, these are like brained bad
empanada fans that are just psychotic.
Uh and I know that Hassan is not that stupid. So, the only thing
the only conclusion that I can jump to is that he is maliciously
lying and then when he freezes his frame with people's personal
information on his stream, that is
intentional. So, the fact that I was getting literally hundreds
of people in my mentions this weekend accusing me of you called
me out earlier. I just wanted to say I felt Hutch's disclosure
chatbot was reasonable. I don't think he's a bad >> Uh,
at this point, I don't think he's a bad guy. He's just saying
like really really things. I think I would like to know about
financial disclosures. I think unfortunately maybe at that point
I would have assumed a financial disclosure but watching people
do the the like kind of the slight of hand with chorus has made
me go you know what I think actually getting explicit wording
that it's a financial arrangement that seems that feels like
it's pretty important to me. Yeah. But thank you for the five.
I appreciate it.
Um, back then I probably like I think I knew that Hutch was in
PV and I felt like it wasn't um like poorly disclosed cuz again
if he would have been doing the content saying I'm being sponsored
by PV right now while I do the content that seems totally fine
to me right of taking Israeli blood money. I was like okay I
don't know where the >> fut thinks it's so bad then why
is the screenshot of the vid uncensored still on his pro Twitter
profile.
Um oh what does he think? He probably thinks like, "Oh, cat's
out of the bag. It's not my real information anyway, so it's
fine. I just want to get Hassan." I think he just wants to get
him. They all just want to get him. >> This is all coming
from, but there's like a lot. There's like people had been in
my mentions accusing me of this before, but kind of more sporadically.
And over the weekend, it was literally like hundreds and then
come to find out he's on What about everyone? Uh, he doesn't
care. This is just They all have this view that like actually
doxing's okay now. So, I'm going to raise awareness of this doxing
and try to get this guy banned. That's more important than protecting
anyone's information.
Wait, his real info didn't even get leaked. Uh, so I think his
real address was included in some filings, but it's an old address,
so it doesn't count anymore. His the thing that was leaked by
Hassan was his zip code. Uh, and it's not even like a zip code
that gets you close to his house. And then city and real name.
His real name was already known. He published that. And his city
was already known. He published that. So like he literally doesn't
none of his information is like
I I don't think it's actual doc's information. I don't think
it's Doc's information by the measure of Twitch either. I don't
think so. I think when he says he was doxed by Hassan, I think
he's basically just lying here because his name is in state only.
Not even city. That's not doxing. No, it's not doxing. Forgotten
Jones. If if my name is Mike from PA and you say you're Mike
from PA, are you doxing me? No. We already had this argument.
Everybody already had this argument and they all understood and
agreed that it was. Why would we rehab this argument? Am I crazy?
We all agreed that this is totally We don't need to have this
argument again. If you publish yourself repeatedly, this is my
full name, right? Oh, where's the Red Bull article? Right? Like
Hutch literally had an article written about him by Red Bull
when when they were sponsoring Optic and it it literally says
his name, his full name. Where is it? Like was this doxing him?
Hutch returns. The trials and tribulations of a YouTube legend.
Uh, except cookies. Sean Hutch Hutchinson is one of the most
enduring figures in the Call of Duty scene. Now the 36-year-old
is back on the competitive circuit, showing you you can have
esports success at any age.
Hutch 2020. It's Sean Hutchinson. Like his his all over the place
with this full name and the city he lives in. So it's like state
and his name is Hutch. Hassan is on his stream last week telling
his audience that we're getting paid to do Israeli propaganda.
He also, >> bro, his username is a shorter version of his
last name. Yes, Hutch is being a useful idiot for people want
him to freak out. He's being used and made to freak out by people
who he should be able to trust and he is making a complete ass
of himself repeatedly. These people do not have his best interest
at heart. He's being told, "Yeah, you were doxed by Hassad."
And he's not stopping to think about it. He's just like the golem.
He's just moving forward. He's got his commands. Destroy Hassan.
That's his only goal right now. And it doesn't matter what he
does to his own credibility to do it. He's going to destroy it.
Okay? He's going to destroy Hassan. He's going to destroy himself.
Accused Progressive Victory of being a slush fund for Destiny's
friends. He accuses us of taking Okay, now hold on. That one,
that one I feel like is it's so hard to differentiate on that
one because there are some cases where I'm like, dude, they're
paying way too much money to people who are complete, i.e. Counterpoints.
I think Counterpoints is getting $2,000 a month when he like
barely was streaming. He was barely making content that was political,
right? It was basically so he could show up to a meeting and
go like, "Yeah, I'm a conservative."
That was it, right?
So like I realistically
that seems a certain way to me but then there were people who
didn't really have platforms who were getting paid and I think
they were doing like other work right on the side. So like I
don't know it's but if you look at just their filings I see exactly
how you would have that precise interpretation. I I think that
is like a reasonable person person's interpretation of this unfortunately
because of the way they went about it. money to make Destiny
look good.
>> Destiny had nothing to do with >> Wait, did they
say that?
Did they say Did Hassan say that he goes out of his these people
go out of their way to make Destiny look good? I don't think
they do >> The progressive victory, he had nothing to do
with it. Like they collaborated a couple times on some canvasing
events, but progressive uh >> he had nothing to do with
it. How do you sit here and say that Destiny had nothing to do
with Progressive Victory? How could you? And like, of course,
Destiny had a ton to do with Progressive Victory, right? I Destiny
said, It's funny what Destiny said. I know that Destiny did so
much more. Destiny made Progressive Victory from the ground up.
He did not. He did not make it from the ground up. He did, you
know, come in with a bunch of the organizers for a lot of their
later events at the end of the last election cycle. Okay. What
is this? Oh, I don't care
that this is related to what we're doing right now. Uh, hold
on. But to say he's like not related is insane.
It's totally insane. >> Uh, but Destiny was not a part
of Progressive Victory Pack. >> He absolutely was a major
part of the pack in like you might be able to say in a non-paid
capacity. This is like saying uh it's not quite the same, but
it's not far off from saying that like well, you know, David
Pacman doesn't have anything to do with Chorus. It's like, well,
he's one of the big people who's involved. Uh, all of the people
you're hiring are from this guy's sphere. The the canvasing operation
are being run are being canvasing operations are being run by
the guy who did all of Destiny's canvasing operations. Like,
it's insane to say that has nothing to do with Destiny.
It's insane.
>> He did not fund Progressive Victory F pack. We did not
talk about Destiny.
>> Uh, he did absolutely through his audience, dude.
He's just lying. Why did Eerite go up and go, "Hey, we need to
fund this DG house. You need to go pin the link right now so
we can fund the DG house. Don't you know, bro?" What? In progressive
victory pack, none of this is based on anything.
So, it's really something that like the >> Why did Destiny
run a bunch of the interviews for the Ohio canvasing event, Hutch?
There's a DG House of like canvasers, I believe, in Ohio. Why
did Destiny run? Why was Destiny's Why was Destiny running and
Destiny's people were running all of the canvasing at Ohio? Why
Why would you just come on and say this with no idea of what
you're talking about? I don't get it. It's actually It feels
like so brain damage to me to come on and talk like this when
you don't know what the actual underlying facts of the matter
are. the biggest left-wing tw uh politics streamer on Twitch
is not only like maliciously lying, knowing full well that his
audience are going to jump in my mentions by the hundreds and
just her no. Uh do we have does somebody have the time stamp
for me where jumps in and asks for funding again? Does anybody
does anybody have this? cuz Erdite comes in and she's like, "Yeah,
we're like $7,000 away or some [__] from our actual
like from being able to get hotels for people." And she's like,
"You need to shield this link. You need to shield this link."
And Desi's annoyed because
he doesn't want to just fund everything off of his audience.
The reason he was supporting
Progressive Victory was because he thought, "Oh, these people
will pick up some of the tab here and I can hand off my funding
my like canvasing operation and they'll pay for it." And they
didn't pay for it. And then they're like, "Destiny, can you spam
the ACT blue link? I want I want that clip again. We just watched
it a couple days ago. I want that clip again because that clip
is critical to understanding that like there was a link here.
Destiny was honestly like doing a lot of the fundraising for
that chapter of Progressive Victory >> harassed the out
of me and lob baseless accusations at me. Literally baseless.
Like no evidence, zero evidence
that PV was this slush fund and we were doing this propaganda.
Like there's nothing to base that off of at all. Okay, we got
this we got this clip right here. There's nothing to base this
off of. >> Question about this is the boring stuff,
>> uh fundraising and stuff. I know you're super busy.
>> Yeah, I think I like it. >> Fundraising for what?
>> We've only got like $70 raised though. So, um if we
want to be able to cover canvasing hotels, we'll have to push
it. Do you want me to >> Wait, like canvasing at hotels
for Wait, what? What? Why would Destiny be involved? Destiny
was not involved. Why would he be doing anything for canvasing?
They've only got $70,
guys. What? I'll link it again. We're trying to raise 6K. I think
they only need three more for the um Nevada event, guys. Here
you go. >> We need more than 3K cuz the 2K that's in there
was raised like independently. >> Well, then
Well, then we need more than 3K. They need They need what? They
need like Wait, 5K, 7K? Really, guys?
We only need Why would Destiny be so invested? Why would Erdite
think Destiny would be invested at all in funding this or promoting
it to his audience? Weird. Isn't that weird? I feel like that's
>> Good luck. >> I love you all. >> Should
I come in tomorrow? What should I do? You're >> What are
we doing for what? >> Are you able to fundra tomorrow?
And if yes, what should I do to help you do that? Cuz I know
that you're busy. I don't want to ruin all your content. We're
also doing the Nevada DG event this weekend. And if we want to
>> Oh, there was a Nevada DG event. Was it just DGG? It
wasn't like Progressive Victory. It was just Why would they Why
would they confusingly misuse DG versus Progressive Victory?
Oh, look. It's prying mind. Pey is pimping this [__]
out. Omegaol. Pee is pimping this [__] out. Omega
lol. Peavey is pimping this [__] out. Omega lol.
>> What is this? This is very confusing. This is like very
very confusing. Come on DJs. Let's fund raise for a progressive
victory. have to raise the money like by tomorrow so we can buy
financial aid hotels for our campusers. >> Well, I I'll
link it and sh again. Boom. Boom. Here you go. Good luck.
>> I linked it. They got a They got another another set
of link. >> Oh, wait. What was that? What was that? That
was uh linked it. >> Wait. Secure.blue.com/donate/pv
Las Vegas. Why did she just call it the DG event when it's PV
Las Vegas? when there's no overlap between these
Can somebody explain that to me? Destiny is not related at all.
Aerodite comes in and calls it the DGG event in Las Vegas. The
link Destiny gives is PV Las Vegas. That's a really confusing
It's a really confusing uh what would you call this? Did Did
Aronite have a stroke? Is this Is this
God damn it? Captain Cathy Pants was there ahead of me out ahead.
[__] It's just going to make a joke. Okay. I will
also say why why Hutch, could you could you explain to me why
you why does Destiny have this imagining of it where where he
feels like people owed him their silence and them not stepping
away over the Pixie stuff and the and the cherry stuff? Why did
Why was he owed that? Because like the entire progressive victory
paid out millions in wages to all these people and the whole
thing only existed because of me on top of a billion other things.
Why? Oh, the whole thing. Well, he he seems to be talking about
that DGG adjacent sphere of progressive victory. Like the idea
that there's no reason to believe this. Okay, there's infinitely
more evidence that this existed and it was like a pseudo slush
fund for Destiny, right? That people were just getting paid out
of that cuz like they were kind of adjacent creators. There's
way more evidence of that than there is of me being involved
in in doxing people. Curious PB advertising on r/ Destiny, but
no connection at all. What would this say? Canvasing update.
Come join the h Come join the house. Hey y'all. My name is Bryce.
I'm the state director for PV and DG's canvasing efforts in Nevada.
Oh, would he have done the same link? There's no way that would
be the same link, right? PV NHouse NC house. Oh, this is a different
one. Donate to the North Carolina PV canvasing house. $100 out
of 200 raised. Okay. Wisconsin, Pennsylvania, Arizona, Ohio.
Ohio. Oh, it's Flat Trace who's doing this stuff, by the way.
Cool. Hey, I'm Flat Trace.
Oh, he's doing Ohio. I got it. I got it. I got it. Wait, where's
Nevada? Right here. Here's our act blue link. How much did they
get? They got to a thousand for this. I wonder what happened
cuz they apparently for the PV Oh, this is a different one. This
is the Nevada house by itself. Wait, PVNV. What was the link
that they just did? PVNV.
I said it.
Las Vegas or sorry, PV Las Vegas
was the thing. Pey
Las Vegas.
What did they get to for fundraising on this? Oh, they got there.
Aerodites. Aerodite shilling got them there, guys. Damn. Damn.
They got a they got another another set of links. It's going
to be the biggest link I've ever seen. So many linked. >> The
greatest the greatest links. >> Um are you >> to
link link again tomorrow? >> Yeah, obviously. Always
>> bug you or do you want me to leave you alone about it?
probably bug you, right? >> Yeah, you can DM me. I linked
it early when you DM me, so just keep Yeah, keep DMing me. I'll
keep linking it. >> Right. Bye. Uh, I'm in Miami as well,
so if you need anything,
>> Cool. Be careful. Don't die. >> Okay, cool. Wow.
So, anyway, we can take >> Not only was he doing these
baseless accusations, he doxed us. He doxed us. He doxed. It's
like prominently featured on his screen. >> Hello. Are
we like I don't know what to say, man. And I mean like I reported
the VOD. The VOD is still up, you know, like you can find the
VOD on his channel. I reported the VOD. I sent an email. >> Oh,
I would say with the Dylan thing that should probably the VOD
should get taken down to like Twitch support. I added them
like if he if if there's no consequence for this like I don't
know what are there just like there's just no rules. Like I don't
understand. It is a blatant violation
of Twitch's doxing policy. Like if you go to their policy, this
is what it says about doxing. Doxing of any kind is prohibited
by Twitch's community guidelines, even if the perpetrators only
expose information available via the public. Banning any mention
of bad empanada in his chat
>> oh, hold on. >> Of their doxing to just bullen
and I think it kind of reveals like what an actual piece of [__]
he is. I mean, he's talking all this [__] yesterday.
Hassan is about banning any mention of bad empanada in his chat
because bad empanada and his audience were going in Hassan's
chat and spamming at Hassan that he was like a zen like a z liberal
zionist genocide supporter like bad empa he was so it's almost
like bad empanada just says this about everybody all of the time
it's almost like bad empanada doesn't necessarily tell the truth
sometimes I I feel like Hutch has just realized this guys bad
empanada lies And then people actually propagate those lies.
That sucks, man. >> Happy to use
as his own personal attack dog >> because he knew bad empanada
was like deranged and psychotic enough to take it to the extremes
that he does. He knows that that kind of behavior from bad empanada
results in relentless harassment from his psychotic fans. He
regularly platformed bad empanada.
In fact, as I said, he showed that video on his stream last week
with these insane accusations. And
as he doxes us, there's like 12 people there's like 12 people
like 12 creators or whatever. I don't even maybe maybe more who
have their personal information
plastered all over Hassan's stream with an audience of 30,000
people. And again, I keep going back to this, but
>> Oh, I see. So you feel like wait I looked at this uh
malicious practice of collecting document refers to the malicious
practice of collecting and doing this stuff
doc often involves bad actors attempting to cause inconvenience
harm. So here's the thing is I do believe that bad empanada was
doing this maliciously like to try to like drive harassment towards
people. So, if you watch the video and you don't like question
this when it's somebody who does this quite frequently, I don't
know how easily you can get away from this or how much I want
to grant like that argument that Hassan wasn't doing this maliciously
when realistically like you sort of create the ability to infinitely
dox people if you do that. Oh, let's just go watch the ad video.
Oh no, there's info in here. No way. No way. Crazy.
But like Hassan doesn't actually believe this. I don't know what
to tell you guys. It's like he doesn't actually believe that
this that Progressive Victory was a slush fund and that we were
doing >> uh No, I think there's like I think there's easily
like reason to believe that that was like kind of a way it was
being used. Like a lot of the creators weren't being paid they
were not being paid to like do anything but show up to like a
meeting once in a while. Like I I'm sorry that's like not enough
to justify the amount of money they were getting. It's it's like
not and I don't know I I think the slush fund thing while it
is not how I feel it was used I understand people who believe
that a little bit Israeli propaganda he doesn't feel he's lying
and then he's using bad empanada as a attack dog and then he
got tired of bad empanada nipping at his heels and so now he
now you ban bad empanada because you're getting harassed when
last week you were more than happy
to have this guys serve as your attack dog as you lie about us
as you like maliciously lie about us. Can can
anyone give me any example of like that lefty media space? Blackpill
lefty media space or like leftist media space. Can anyone give
me a like a single example of a creator that actually gives a
about the truth? I'm serious. Like I just want one. Like give
me one creator in that space that rigorously fact checks things
that does not engage in >> He's not gonna like my answer.
He's not going to like my answer at all. He's going to hate my
answer, but my answer is probably going to be straighter. Dude,
Straighter Raid does a lot of like actually following and like
fact-checking. Like I'm sorry. She actually is really informed
on a lot of stuff from like that perspective. That would be my
answer. But maybe Hutch has examples of straight raid lying if
Hutch wants to. That would be my example. Now, if Hutch could
show me straight away not caring about the truth regularly or
>> this kind of conspiracy theory crazy nonsense that actually
places a heavy emphasis on getting stories correct. Like just
give me one, you know, between like Majority Report, Breaking
Points, uh, you know, Bad Faith podcast, uh, >> Wait, I
feel like Breaking Points is pretty committed to being factually
correct. No, hold on. >> Wait, in what universe is Breaking
Points not committed to the truth in some way? Uh, Space Ghost,
thank you for the very much for the five gifted. Let's go. I
think that puts us I think we're three subs away from another
two hours on stream. Three subs. Let's go. >> Stream all
of his or all of his orbiters. Like, do is there a single example
of people that don't that don't engage in this kind of like crazy
conjecture? It's not even conjecture. It's like it's not even
it's not it's not based on anything. These accusations are completely
baseless. Hassan knows
that that Bad Panata doxes maliciously smears people lies. He
knows that. >> Okay. Yes. >> He platformed him from
time to time because he found him useful in his fight against
like Ethan and at times me. Like he doesn't focus on me. I'm
I'm a much more like smaller creator and there were other creators
in this pool. So like he was using this bad paninata to smear
like a ton of us that were speaking up about the Taylor Loren
article is what >> do I think that was what he did? Okay,
I don't know if Hassan knew that Breaking Points is news, but
are they like factually incorrect? Are they like lying
to a larger extent than most like online content creators? I
guess like I don't think that they're like I think they have
a bend, but I don't think they lie. Like having a bias is different
from lying, right? Like there's a there's a everybody understood
this as of like a month ago. Everybody understood that there's
factual reporting and there's like opinion pieces, right? and
that like when you look at someone's factual reporting you have
at a certain standard and you look at the opinion pieces you
have a different standard >> but we've seem to we seem
to just totally lost that so he was using this video to smear
me lying loner box he knew that bad empanada was lying he just
repeated those lies because he knew we were going to get from
crazy idiot people in his audience I wish I wish he hadn't just
kept saying over and over again Destiny's chef Destiny's private
chef got paid by progressive victory Yes, he's chef. He's chef.
It's like, okay, I'm okay. I I get that that's a good line. I
understand that that's where you want to go, but like
come on, man. I don't know. They're all paid. I It seemed like
the way they were getting paid was under like digital marketing.
I don't think that's what Lyken did if I'm if I'm not misremembering.
I thought Lyan did like like Lyan helped them set up and he like
did various stuff at events. I didn't think he got really I didn't
think he was like going to the meetings and [__]
but maybe I'm wrong. It blows my mind. You You can call me a
prick. You can say that I focus on too much of this or too much
of that. You can have differences of opinions when it comes to
me. I never maliciously smear people ever. I I would never just
make something up about someone and then just like roll with
it. I would never knowingly lie about someone just because I
didn't like them. That is not how I operate. Anyways, that's
what I'm dealing with these days. >> Come on, man.
Uh is that true? I feel like
I feel like he just like maybe Okay, hold on. Maybe he's got
one defense and that is that he will just he'll just say things
are wrong without understanding or knowing. Like I just watched
him basically lie about Destiny's involvement in PV. Totally.
Totally [__] lied about Destiny's involvement in
PV, but he I guess doesn't know. And so if he doesn't have the
uh if he doesn't have the intent then okay I maybe he lied about
Quean.
I don't wait where did he lie about Queman? Lying requires the
intent. Sure.
But he was also just complaining Pumpern Nickel about like the
commitment to getting facts correct like actually factecking
things. And I've not seen that exact thing from Hutch.
Otherwise it's just being wrong. Yeah. But if you make no effort
to educate yourself, if you make no effort to look into things
and you just say then yeah, that's not I don't know. Like people
people could say it's not lying. There's something bad there
that's worse than just being wrong, right? It's not him operating
in good faith and just being wrong. It's him not caring to be
correct. It's a little different, >> guys. I don't even
know. I I really I don't even know um like what to say. Like
I see the stuff pop. It's it's a it's a crazy thing to open up
your feed and you're seeing all these like >> like I would
assume that most of the people who know Hutch and were in PV
would go, "Whoa, whoa, Hutch, you're saying Destiny had nothing
to do with PV. That's not correct." And then I assume because
Hutch is committed to telling the truth that he went on stream
and corrected that. Yes, I should have an actual correction from
Hutch on that misinformation.
Yes, that nobody would have watched him say this and I'm sure
at least one or two creators would have seen these clips floating
around. There's no way that he would just lie about that completely
or sorry be totally incorrect and he's committed to the facts.
Nobody corrected him and he's never updated anything. Is that
what I'm led to believe right now? Cuz I I would love to just
see the Hutch correction on this that yes, Destiny was actually
quite involved in PB, right? Surely we've got that coming. >> Intense
accusations and you're not even entirely sure what you're being
>> Hey hooligans, thank you for the five gifted. Let's
go. Thank you. Thank you. >> Appreciate it. And you're
just looking at it and it's like and then you're confronted with
the
um realization that these people are accusing you of the most
insane you could imagine and they genuinely believe it. Like
they actually believe it like to their core. They're not joking.
Uh I know it's super late here, but you know it's illegal to
dox people in California. It's not just against witch policy.
Um listen I'm not I I don't listen. I'm not trying to >> Is
he going to watch the legal mindset video? like, "No, I'm not
trying to like sue people or press charges against people." Uh,
I'm not dealing with that [__] headache. Pass.
>> Okay. So, he's on to this [__] and he stops
it and he starts talking about >> I don't know, you know,
like >> I thought I thought about watching this, by the
way, the Andrew Wilson video. I don't know if I'm going to watch
it or not, though. >> Certainly, he's violating Twitch's
policies, but I don't know if he would meet the threshold legally
to face any kind of accountability. Um, it's interesting because,
you know, many people in the UK would consider Ben to >> honestly
more like more than the more than the doxing, which I think is
really bad, like very bad for one of the biggest rumors on the
platform to casually dox like two dozen people is pretty crazy.
Um, but what bugs me more than the doxing was this the the lying
like he was maliciously lying to his audience about what progressive
victory was about and about like why we were a >> Wait,
Hutch. Wait, hold on. Hassan did say it wasn't like a Zionist
slush fund or or like a Zionist propaganda outlet, right? I think
Hassan did say that and then Hassan corrected and said, "Well,
it's a Destiny slush fund." And while that is not 100% accurate,
I understand why some people would have that impression for sure.
Like I think that's far more forgivable to that's more of a perception
thing and they did have a bunch of people who were friends with
Destiny who started getting paid like basically is that that
being like the primary requirement, right? >> Part of that
program what we were doing those smears are insane to me. It's
crazy. Um, I think people show you their their whole app sometimes
and you get you get a glimpse into how they work and I think
this was a very honest moment ironically for Hassan because what
he demonstrated is that if he doesn't like someone or if he feels
like someone if he feels like for whatever reason he wants to
discredit someone, he'll just say whatever. He doesn't give a
like he will say whatever which is you know I I'm always surprised
when I see people act that way because I I some people call me
like call me naive but I'm generally optimistic about people
like I like to think better of people. I tend to be charitable.
I mean sometimes like listen you know I'm biased right? So like
as soon as I identify someone as >> Okay. So I'm going
to weave into here now. I'm going to start weaving in some of
the responses from Hassan. So Hassan went and responded to this.
I I just got the a clips for this. So, we'll we'll check it out.
It might not be clipped up the best, but we'll see. >> Liable.
Wait, someone just said
what is this? This guy just got banned. Wait, hold on. What the
[__] Someone just said I doxed I streamed the address
of Dylan Burns just said you streamed his attie. Is that true?
Why the would that be true? Do you think I know who the Dylan
Burns is or what? How would that be relevant to you streaming
his address his address and when he's like featured in a bad
empanada video? >> He does,
let alone find his address and then stream it. >> Yeah.
Also, like I'm I think he might have just like not known at all
and he like doesn't want to say he didn't, but he doesn't believe
he did. He wasn't trying to, but like he's like, "Wait, did I
wait? Hold on. >> What the [__] Are people
just like now they've decided to just like make new and and unique
and creative things up? Is that what's going on? Void going.
So, he didn't show Dylan's address. That's that's false, but
he did he did show some information on Dylan. That was probably
way too much. Okay, that response is funny as it's not really
that funny, but whatever. Um,
Hutch responds to this. There's no honest way to try and claim
that Be that Be wasn't doxing us. Lol. He posted personal information
of several creators, then accuses us of being paid to do Israeli
propaganda. The point was to maliciously lie about us and mobilize
people to harass us, which happened. Wait, did it happen based
on your PII, though? Hold on. Which one of these creators got
harassed via their PII? Like, yeah, he's mobilizing harassment.
Sure, he's like he's like lying about you guys and people are
going to come and like use that lie to attack you. That's bad,
but that's different than the the like doxing thing. I would
imagine if you're like there's just whatever uh time samp I watched
I watched this whole thing 42X it's still doxing it is still
still doxing right he did dox them but he didn't uh it's not
them using like the picture that's painted by this which is fine
I'm just being about it is that they use that information to
harass people right in any case I think Hassan pushed back against
the Israeli propaganda thing did he not I'm pretty confident
Hassan literally said no no I don't think that's true am I wrong
on that someone tell me if I'm wrong on that cuz I'm Pretty sure
that's true that Hassan said, "No, no, no. I don't think they're
Israeli like slush fun or I don't think they're like Zionist
propaganda or something. They approach me." Blah blah blah blah
blah. Anyway, Hutch continues. Hassan then platforms Be's video,
amplifying, repeating, and expanding on those smears. So, this
is wrong. I I think it's wrong in that Hassan actually explicitly
said, "No, no, they're not Israeli propaganda." I think bad is
just like making up right now. Hassan referenced me by name during
his stream and has accused me of being a war tourist before.
Don't know why he's pretending not to know my name. He showed
my n-digit zip code, not five-digit, on stream, which showed
the street I live on. Full document has my entire home address.
The full I probably wouldn't include that part. Personally, I
don't know why. Why? Why would you do that? Why would you go?
Also, if you do want to harass me though, my full address would
be available if you look a little deeper.
What? Why? For what purpose would you do this? Is it because
he moved? I don't know. I don't I literally don't know.
Didn't that host burn down? Oh, maybe WebG. Maybe that's it.
Dude, why would people I don't understand why people do this.
I understand it sucks to get like somebody to put somebody puts
information on screen. You feel like they should get punished.
You want them to get punished for it, so you like say, "Yeah,
this is this is my thing, but I man I don't know.
It sucks. Sucks in both cases, but whatever."
Okay. Asan reads a few of these tweets, responds back again.
>> I just >> Oh, hold on. I just use this as an opportunity
to try to once again uh implement this like fake deplatforming
stupid deplatforming initiative claiming that I was actually
doxing people. Um looking at FEC filings myself included for
because I have looked at my own FC filings as well on this broadcast
which is publicly available data uh that actually doesn't show
the full identity or or the full addresses of people is not doxing.
It's never been doxing. a big part of this. Um, >> I mean,
it could be doxing. The way Bad Empatada is doing it, he's trying
to collect it to harass people, right? It could totally be doxing.
I think again, this is um I don't really have to go through it
again. Just I think there's like a line where you can go from
like public interest. I I feel like these groups do give money
to people with like without without like a proper, you know,
obligation of any kind. And it's it's kind of weird and and it's
weird how they just like pay people to talk and they don't follow
like what seems to be like the market rate for any of this. They
just go and do this, right? I I think they're like criticisms
here that you could go down. Oh, this is after progressive victory
stage. Hold on. We'll go look at that. >> Revolves around
going on Open Secrets, which is the website that Bad Empan >> HQ
is the Hutchinson question. Okay. kind of see what Hutch has
been doing for the past week because I just I feel like I feel
like Hutch is willing to amplify stuff if people tell him it
without really checking in very very like concretely. I feel
like he's being pushed in direction. He's like a useful idiot
right now and it's not good for him. It's not good for his reputation.
I think he needs to reel it back and like actually do some facteing
on things before he just runs with using >> in my opinion.
Okay, ironically enough, these guys aren't even mad at Bad Empanada
for making the video, but more so bad mad at me, which uh for
for not only responding to the video, but also adding additional
information about this organization that I knew about. Now, of
course, that probably allows you to understand that
uh this is not really a sincere like I would say from my memory,
I think Hutch ran with like the Omidar dark money thing for Taylor
Loren with zero factchecking. He just ran with that, right? He
just wanted to like smear Taylor Loren. So, he just ran with
that immediately. From from my memory, from my recollection,
I'm pretty sure he did that, right? And then eventually like
you get, you know, Loner Box or Destiny look into it and they
come up with like a tenuous argument you can make based on how
the LLC set up and but Hutch didn't do any of that work to even
he was like lazy. He didn't even do the work to try to like sweep
and have like some plausible deniability. He just went hard.
He just went super [__] hard. A sincere fear that
people have about doxing or whatever, but instead it's just to
use as an opportunity to [__] farm some drama and
clout. But the notion that like uh Destiny was not heavily involved
with Progressive Victory is is of course incorrect. He himself
has admitted that he was like playing a formative role in Progressive
Victory and all this stuff. So that was again like I said aside
from >> that's another example of Hutch doesn't care to
be accurate. Hutch just is going to Hutch is like I'm right,
they're wrong. I'm good. They're bad. I will shill as hard as
I can for my side and then eventually we'll win. That's all that's
in Hutch's head at all. Having Brianna Woo work with the organization,
it made me believe that it wasn't super serious. Having said
that, they have it was the FCC side directly, not open secrets,
by the way. Okay. FC side
>> Okay. Uh, so we have that response from Assan. And then,
okay, I'll do the PV tweet. And then this breaks into like some
defamation stuff, which is like the the malicious lying. I don't
know. So, for some reason, Progressive Victory comes out and
says the dumbest thing. Okay. They they tweet out September 5th
in order to defend Hassan's honor. Progressive Victory comes
in and they go, "Listen guys, we can be the dumbest person, the
dumbest people involved here. Make no mistake." And they say,
"It was our past FC filing that inadvertently docked Dylan Burns
and other creators we worked with last year. Creators who use
our FC filing as a source are not at fault." Uh there's absolutely
no reason to include the addresses or zip codes or any of that
stuff. You could easily just blur that out and do the same piece.
There's no harm to just not using like people's full information
or as much information as you can. There's only one reason to
do that and it's because you and it's by the way from a guy who
has repeatedly done so to intimidate people, right? Bad Panata
does dox people to intimidate them 100%. And he's done it for
a long time. So it was it was doxing and you can't just absolve
all creators who showed that dox because you feel like you're
the person who originated the the information. That's not how
that works. But I did think it was really funny that they announced
this and then if memory serves they pivot this into announcing
that they're actually going to go back to supporting like more
like very far-lefty progressives which is very weird to me that
they put these together. Uh we are a digital third place with
a volunteer digital third place. I is that a saying third place?
Oh, it is a Oh, right.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're home in your workplace and it's a third
place. I got it right. No, I knew that I knew that term. I knew
that term. I've heard that term before. I said to look it up.
We are a digital third place with a volunteer electoral organization
sprinkled on top. Our goal is to become infamous for being the
Democrat's greatest threat in the primary and but their greatest
ally in the general. Our leadership is is this Sam Draola? This
is Sam Dresmala and then some other people. Pey hired Brianna
Woo in a contract position in 2023 when we were new in the space
and trying to make contact with more creators. We cut ties with
Brianna in December 2023 and for good reason. Oh,
I didn't actually read that part before. And for good reason.
What? Wait, did they expand on that? Did they expand on that
at all? Wait. And for good reason. Good riddance.
We got an old man who can spit on Brianna Woo. She might be into
that, but
shame on the go.
All right. What's the good reason? I mean, I know the good reason.
She literally can't get anything done. She micromanages other
people when she can't get her own work done. She is generally
like unbearable to be around for any length of time. I understand
all of these things, but what's their reason?
As far as I know, they genuinely found her difficult to work
with. Yes, she wouldn't do her own job. She would like She's
awful. She's just awful. She's just awful. Okay, the red bar
explosion sound effect. Like, uh, hold on. Like this. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Dude, my
soundboard needs to be reorganized really bad. Damn.
Okay.
As for Destiny, last year, our media program consisted of trying
to unite the audiences of as many political creators as possible
in order to get them to cross over onto each other's content
and advertise PV's organizing program. What we quickly discovered
is that most creators have very little desire to do either. With
that, we scuttled our media program after the election and have
not continued to mix liberal creators with our leftist values.
This year, with stronger community leadership, we have doubled
down on the things we are best at, building our community and
helping elect the candidates that they chose choose to support.
Below, we have attached our revised mission statement published
just prior to this drama unfolding. Built by the internet,
built by the internet for America, progressive victory is a new
kind of political institution seamlessly marrying the electoral
impact and volunteer power of traditional progressive organizations
with the culture and community of digital third places dedicated
to pushing the Democratic party to the left. We partner with
leftalign content creators to activate their disaffected terminally
online audiences, converting them into lifelong on the ground
organizers, providing the necessary structure and resources to
empower viewers into volunteers. Our innovative community first
model utilizes familiar online spaces to introduce and demystify
the world of political organizing. Progressive victory embraces
queer neurode divergent new to activism volunteers of all backgrounds,
ethnicities, and abilities. Over the long term, we aim to mainstream
the online progressive power block burgeoning within the Democratic
party and prove that it is that it and us are too big to ignore.
Damn. PB making their snarkle left debut. I guess so. It's so
funny that like they just totally [__] on both Destiny
and Brianna Woo. It's just so funny to me that they just come
out and they're like, "Fuck these people." Actually, these people
[__] suck. As you can see, our core organizing strategy
is committing committed to replacing centrist Dems with real
progressives. Does that sound like either Briana Woo or Destiny?
One final note, scrutinize us, criticize us, love us, hate us,
call us out if you like, but our community is not Zionist. We
back Mdani, and we will back many more like him. You'll just
have to let our future actions speak for themselves.
[__] lib supremacy. Oh, damn. I did find it weird
that they just came out and were like doc creators can't dox
using our information. Yeah, they can. They that that's just
like the dumbest take. They just came out of nowhere. I have
a little I have a little bit of like love for them. Just that
they're like, "Yeah, Destiny." But yeah, no, people can use your
public filings to docs. They can definitely collect that stuff
and try to publish it to harass other people. That's just facts.
Yeah. Anyway, anyway, this somehow pushes into Hutch claiming
that he's going to possibly look into like a like a defamation
lawsuit. What? Huh?
How is Hutch going to look into a defamation lawsuit? I assume
this is over the Desi slush fund. >> Confused about what
PB was. He was knowingly
malicious. The more appropriate word >> here, let's back
it up. >> Progressive victory. >> I don't know what
this was. >> Making it up. It's just straight up true that
that's what he accused his friends of doing. That's the story.
That's the story. Um, Zionist and they will call you a Destiny
orbiter even though I have identifies you as an enemy for >> man
that explains that all of Destiny's
>> responded to PV tweets by the way. Uh, link linkers
>> friends are being paid by a slush fund. >> This
is what they do. Like when that crowd ident >> Wait, what?
Creators who use our FEC filing as a source are not at fault
is what it says right here. Matt Slice. Yeah, Matt Slice. They're
literally saying like don't blame anybody who's using our our
source as a our filing as a source. But obviously bad empanada
used their thing as a source and bad empanada is at fault.
So
yeah. Yeah. You as an enemy for deviating even just 1%. >> Oh,
I didn't watch the Ethan Hutch thing. I'm guessing that would
be unbearable too >> from their orthodoxy. They will call
you a Zionist and they will call you a Destiny orbiter even though
I have not spoken to Destiny since January. Like >> are
you a Destiny orbiter? Hush >> I have never been a Destiny
or Orbiter. Yeah, the whole situation is just >> Aren't
you Wait, isn't he starting a podcast with Aerodite right away?
Is it um the person who like swept most for Destiny who's like
dedicated to rehabilitating Destiny's public image has been for
weeks and months and well months honestly years at this point
but months for sure. No, I I like listen, we we cover politics,
you know. I don't know how much you guys cover politics these
days, but if you're a >> dude boom boom, he's doing the
same thing in real time, guys. His nose is itchy. It's itchy.
>> No, I I like Listen, we we cover politics, you know?
I don't know how much you guys cover politics. >> Any any
gold diggers? any gold diggers >> these days. But if you're
a political creator, you know, you hop into this arena and you
kind of know like one of the things you have to just make peace
with is that you're dealing with people that have, you know,
pretty big. So that doesn't sound likely. Hutch, am I crazy?
Did he actually accuse them
>> Here's what he said. Assan said in no uncertain terms
he wasn't being sort of ambivalent about it. Is that the right
word? ambivalent meaning mixed feelings, contradictory ideas
about Yeah, he was not being ambivalent about it. He said straight
up, it is what it is. Pave is a
slush fund.
That is what he said. He wasn't speculating that it might be.
He said that is what it is. His friends
were that is what he said. mixed feelings, contradictory ideas
about so yeah, he was not being ambivalent about it. He said
straight up, it is what it is. Pave is a pro Zionist slush fund.
That is what he said. He wasn't speculating that it might be.
He said that is what it is. His friends
worked with progressive victory.
Ambiguous. Is that the word I'm looking for? I feel like those
words are similar. Ambiguous. Unclear or inexact.
Open to more than one interpretation. That would be the more
appropriate word. He wasn't being ambiguous about it.
Oh, mic. Hold on. Wait. When did the mic come back or when did
the mic go out? I must have re must have shut it off. Whoops.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Sorry. I'm saying I'm I'm trying to look for
this video, the progressive victory video from Hassan cuz I don't
remember this right muted before you rewinded. Oh, I was like,
"Oh, is he talking about Hassan or Banabanata?" Okay, but it
became clear eventually. So, so he's saying Hassan said that.
I'm pretty sure Hassan didn't say that. Hutch tweet response.
Okay, give me a second. I'm pretty confident. I could have sworn.
So, that's like my memory from before,
but I don't They're debunking malicious smears made by the same
people it looks like they're defending in the first tweet. I'm
genuinely confused by this thread. Hutch is very often confused.
That says a lot about your political myop myopia. Then if you
want to be serious about changing minds, you're going to have
to actually treat criticism seriously and you know talk to people.
How is it not contradictory to absolve the creators including
Hassan who used the FC filings while smearing PV? Then go to
on to address and debunk the smears by the same person they tried
to absolve.
Need to go see the Hassan part again.
Where is the Hassan part? Hassan. Somebody linked it to me. Give
me a second. I'll find it. I think it's in content suggestions.
Give me a sec. Where is this? Am I crazy? [__] Somebody
had linked it to me before. I can't find. Hold on. Let's uh get
Carrier out of here. I don't like hearing his thoughts on anything.
Why? Okay. If you don't want to be known as the Destiny slush
fund. Yeah, I know they don't. I'm trying to find uh
Yeah, Carrie is just an energy vampire in every sense of the
word. I just don't even want him around. I'm looking for We need
a clip. We need the actual video so I can search transcript.
Uh, I'm just paused. So, we'll we'll find it here.
Progressive victory 3 days ago. I think we got to go back more
than 3 days ago, right? Am I crazy? Oh, maybe maybe I can watch
through Dylan Burns or some >> an event to
>> Here's like the No, that's the that's the loner box
one. Is there a why I rejected progressive victory? Oh, this
won't be enough. Oh, that's the progressive victory part. There
was a Zionist people, myself included, to let our fuselves. I
think the reason why people, myself included, assumed that there
was a Zionist association with the uh with the organization,
even though I knew that they like were working with like obviously
people who were uh anti-Israel as well, you know, they weren't
just like only working with pro-Israel people was because of
the Banaoo and Destiny association. It's like very understandable
when when an organization chooses to to build uh on their on
their foundations by like uh you know working with these kinds
of groups especially especially in their in their development
phase like they are actively working with uh a guy who is is
at that point very famous for uh being a a Hutch plays a clip.
All right, we got a clip from Hutch. That's good. one other Hutch
thing apparently here.
What is he going to say? Is he gonna say Ethan wasn't doxing
people when >> Here's a a video clip of Ethan Klein doxing
a random Instagram commenter on his show. Ethan go through the
guy's Instagram. Brings up that. What are we calling doxing?
Like hold on. Doxing meaning filing filing a lawsuit like a public
like a public filing of a lawsuit. We're calling that doxing.
>> Oh no.
Oh no. Oh no. We're calling. So I >> So if you wanted to
go cover that filing and you used Denim's name, which was private
up until that point, up until it was revealed,
is that not anything close to or adjacent to doxing at all? I
like I would say yeah, depending on how you're using it, right?
I But I remember I don't know why his first why is his like gut
reaction to go no. Why is that? >> What he's talking about
here? some guy I think it was the guy who
replied to a Hila Instagram post where she had gotten a tattoo
of I think a star of David and I think the person left a comment
saying like you belong in Wait, no way Tequila Sunset there's
no way that he did all of those things. Ethan pulled the lawsuit
filing up on his stream with Denim's name in full view. Now that's
not necessarily so bad. That included it in the publish segment
and put it in the thumbnail. Like he put her name in the thumbnail.
Like that's just seems like objectively he's just trying to do
these same tactics back on Denims, right? Okay. And to be clear,
that's way worse than what happened to Hutch,
right? I think that's way worse than what happened to Hutch.
Like clearly and blurred his lawyer's name out, her full name.
Yeah, I believe so. Yes. Forgotten Jones. Cuz he put it in the
lawsuit and nobody had known her name before this, which what
uh that's brutal. This is why I'm afraid to say or not afraid
to say, this is why I have to say like Hutch is the golem. He's
just like the useful idiot. He's the vanguard. He's like he's
like the magnet, right? He's the guy they're throwing out in
front and he's going to say all of the really stupid to give
them all plausible deniability to go like, "Look, there's somebody
out there saying all the dumb things that we don't want to say,
right? We don't want to get caught doing this." And he's just
going to do that and he's going to flare out
Uh, it just sucks that he has no interest in like committing
to having, I don't know, like an understanding of these things
before he talks about them >> in hell or something like
that. And then Ethan brought up the guy's like public Instagram
when he was live streaming on YouTube. Are we calling that doxing?
Is that doxing? You're saying yes, that is. Hold on a second.
Hold on. Hang on. Shut the door for just a minute. Hold on. to
publicly identify or publish private information about someone
especially as a form of punishment or revenge.
How is that doxing?
He is a publish private
about someone to publicly identify or publish private information
about someone especially as a form of punishment or revenge.
How is that doxing?
>> He is a I I presume he means how is filing a real legitimate
lawsuit the same as that? But Ethan obviously went a little further
with the content, right? Like a little further with the content.
I don't know. You might be able to argue, maybe there's an argument
for like, okay, by filing the lawsuit, Ethan wasn't engaged in
doxing, right? But if he did all the things that people are saying
in chat, if he did the thumbnail thing, if he pulled it up on
stream, if he did all these things, they're referring to both.
Holy xrray. The Instagram thing is also doxing. Well, sorry,
the Instagram thing is also what he's talking about here at different
points, but he's clearly making the argument about denims, too.
So, the Instagram thing is pretty rough.
I don't know if I call it doxing, but it is like you are trying
to har get that guy harassed as much as you can. He also docks
the IG guy and his mom. I mean, it's a I don't know. It's a little
different when you're going through comments, but it's not a
lot different when you have that size of platform probably. It's
like probably not great. Here's Ethan Klein saying he used a
range cult on a random guy in retribution for him leaving a negative
IG comment which resulted in his teenage sister receiving death
threats. Cool.
Cool. Okay. Uh, gross. Very gross. Okay, we're continuing on
with this. >> His friends,
many of his friends
worked, collaborated with Progressive Victory.
Therefore, if A, then B, right? Like, therefore, he is accusing
his friends
of working with a pro-Zionist slush fund. You cannot, that is
an
logical conclusion.
So I say that's what the headline is. We should never let him
live that down. It would probably be bad if you make them contend
with that point specifically. Hutch.
I mean, look, I don't think it's very hard to convince people
that what Assan said was insane because it was it was just so
there are just so many facts that that that don't line up with
that narrative, which is again that's how you know that it was
a malicious lie and not him just being kind of confused about
what PB was. He was knowingly
maliciously lying. Hm. >> To be honest with you, man, I
have thought about like
like should I go talk to a defamation lawyer? Like I'm I'm thinking
about it like to be honest with you cuz it's so egregious. >> Is
it? It's just that egregious. I do I do want to see. Apparently
he pulls a clip. So we got a clip maybe coming in just a minute
here. >> But I don't know, man. I just like from everything
I've read like uh defamation stuff is just really
hard to prove and it's a big old headache and I just don't know.
But like I don't know. Like I feel like I have a legitimate grievance
here. Like I'm for sure off about this whole thing and it is
impacting me. >> You'd have to say he knowingly lies and
you you definitely couldn't prove it but >> because his
followers are spamming my feed with these defamatory claims.
Like I feel like I don't know how to establish reputational harm
or any kind of like damages that I've incurred financially because
of this. But it's a it's if if pe random people that don't follow
me see one of my posts and then they pull up one of my posts
and they look at the replies and they're seeing a bunch of people
accusing me of this thing that may that might make a lot of people
be like I don't want to do and I don't want to I don't like this
creator. It'll cost a half a million plus. It'll have a hard
path in California. It'll pry into everything in your personal
life. Yeah, that's the other thing I just But man, there's there
like I for sure have a legitimate grievance here. The malicious
nature of it is just what really gets to me. >> Okay, hold
on. This is from the previous >> video here from seven
days ago. >> Now, I don't know if I'm gonna I don't know
if I'm going to count this because I don't think I don't think
he was talking about them right here, but we'll >> So,
last last Wednesday on his stream was watching a video from Bad
Empanada.
>> the name of the video is like >> all these slap
tubers are paid Zionist chills or something like that. And then,
you know, I find this video last night. I don't know if I was
the first
>> I I thought I thought this was the clip right here to
find it. I don't know if Lonerbox found it before I did. Um I'm
kind of surprised that it took me a minute to find this video
because in this video bad empanada shows like partial intentional.
So, the fact that I was getting literally hundreds of people
in my mentions this >> I'm just looking for where I'm looking
for where he plays this clip >> and also turned around
but also turned around and basically created this like pay structure
for a bunch of uh Destiny's friends. He's accusing Pey of being
a slush fund. That's what he's saying. He's saying that they
set it up to give the appearance of doing political advocacy,
but all it was was a slush fund for Destiny's friends. No, I
don't think he's saying that's the only thing it was. In fact,
I think he's saying explicitly it's not the only thing it is.
I think he acknowledges some of the other stuff they've done.
He's accusing me of defrauding
people who he That's what he's doing. He's accusing me and everybody
else that was a part of this of defrauding the people who donated
money to PV by treating it like a slush fund. That is such a
crazy thing to accuse someone of. There is. >> So again,
that's not Zionist there. I was looking around for Zionist where
I could find like the Zionist part, but I can't find it. >> No
basis for that accusation. There's nothing that you can >> I
think I think any thoughts at a defamation lawsuit go away when
the guy being accused, the guy who had a lot of private dealings
with Progressive Victory, who helped set up a lot of Progressive
Victory, like sorry, helped as in his infrastructure he set up
for his canvasing operations, was transferred over essentially
whole wholesale to Progressive Victory in a lot of ways, right?
And he was still involved, as far as I know, communicating with
them. You say he doesn't have any involvement and it's not a
slush fund, but he's like literally saying you guys got paid
because of because of him. That's why you got paid. I don't know.
I don't know how you could possibly accuse somebody of defamation
when when the guy himself is saying, "No, no, no. That's why
you got paid cuz you were friends with me." It can be Whoops.
Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Point to
say this is why I think that
it it's completely
baseless and he is lying. Like they have no no viewership. Like
there is no real >> dude. There must be something else
in this Hassan video where where Hassan actually says Zionist
slush fund because I could have sworn that's what Hutch is saying
he said about him. Right. So I almost I feel like I have to go
find that video right now and try to figure out where that's
being said cuz to me it's so [__] annoying if he
just lies about if he's just lying about what Hassan said that's
crazy. That's even worse. You're like accusing him of lying while
lying yourself. That's so [__] bad. That Hassan must
have said it, right? Am I crazy? >> Justification for like
tapping into these dudes and giving them like three grand or
$1,000 or even $500 to just like go to an event. And >> now
he's doing the clout thing, bro. Now he's doing the clout thing.
I guess if you don't have 30,000 concurrents, you have no value
to do any kind of >> goes in a slush. But that's not what
he's saying over here in this video. He's saying the defamation
is that we're you called me like a Zionist. You said it was a
Zionist slush fund, which is different. The Destiny thing, you
have a lot of plausible deniability there because Destiny himself
has said this and like there's an appearance of stuff where it's
like a bunch of Destiny's friends get hired right after they
hired Brianna Woo, right? I think you can you can make that argument
of it appearing that way and well, it could be corrected or not.
I don't even know if you'd need to correct it with um with the
Destiny log, right? I think this basically gives you enough plausible
deniability you could just say it. I that's what I'm thinking
too. But Hutch is being so imprecise with his language here.
>> Difficult for you to claim defamation because you could
be considered a public figure. No, the thing is is that he in
in the video that I'm reacting to,
he it it is so obvious that he's lying. It is so obvious that
he is lying. Otherwise, like he's saying that it's a Zionist
slush fund that approached him to collaborate. How the How does
that make any sense? Like Hassan must have said this, right?
Somewhere as a Zionist slush fund. >> You'd have to be
able to prove actual malice. That That's what I'm saying right
here. That's that's what I'm referring to. How is that not primasy
malicious? A pro-Zionist slush fund approached him to collaborate.
How does that make any sense? That doesn't make any sense. Big
communities, they're going to be really passionate about these
issues and and that's fine. Like if you want to call me bald
or ugly or whatever, whatever, like that stuff does not hurt
my feelings after like 16 years on the internet. If you want
to attack my positions and say that I have a a bad argument or
something like that, that's fair game. I might even concede that
it's a bad argument in this case or that case. But to accuse
me and everybody else that was involved with that pack of like
this kind of corruption, and they took it even further. I mean,
they were they were he was claiming that they were paying us
to be, you know, uh, silent on Gaza. There's nothing to point
to to justify that claim. Like nothing. That's a really really
>> I would have to look at the full list of creators again
cuz there was 10 to 15 of us I think. But if I had to guess like
trying to remember the names that were the other people that
were in the um the PV creator program >> turned into >> Sorry.
I like I have to go find this now cuz I Hutch must have seen
this again. Is this as close as it gets? Oh no, that's not it
either. Oh me. This is like the same thing, dude. No way. >> You
AK munch because no strings attached. That kind of feels like
what you're saying. You took money from a Zionist group during
a genocide. No PR spinning and changing the facts. The >> That's
By the way, he's reading comments on a chorus video there. Dude,
I can't I can't find it. And I'm like, dude, there's no way there's
no possible way Hutch is sitting here making up, right? Well,
accusing Hassan of defamation. Like, I feel like if you're going
to say, I I'm consulting a defamation lawyer cuz Hassan said
this about me, you'd probably want to make sure you got a clip
of him saying that about you before you go on stream and say
he said that about you, right? I maybe I'm just
>> I would guess that probably like 75% of them were explicit.
>> No, I'm looking for >> anti-Israel there. There
were a lot. I mean, it's progressive
victory. Okay. It wasn't like milktoast lib victory. It wasn't
like centrist victory. It was progressive victory. Um,
and a lot of the people that were in that program, there were
multiple self-described communists, Marxists.
I don't remember exactly, but I would guess that 75% of them
were explicitly
anti-Israel,
but okay. >> Really heinous accusation >> in this.
>> That's the other thing, too. I thought about reaching
out to PV. I thought about reaching out to cuz I have a direct
line to the to the guy who runs it, um, Sam. I thought about
hitting him up and being like, "Yo, have you thought about like
suing? Maybe we can get a class action going, you know?" I I
mean, >> Especially when people are >> That's like
a shot.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, when you think about it in that
crowd, it's like the mortal sin because, you know, they're anti-
capitalist and they're anti-colonial. Like that's like that or
anti-imperialist, whatever you want to >> Okay. Hold on.
We're we're going through like his H3 stuff and this as well.
>> But while simultaneously still, >> Dude, Sam wants
to be on the PV side, so hold on. And he's playing this [__]
right at the end. >> And aside like for for for what purpose
now? Like why am I doing this? Like am so do that for the past
22 months. They did that pretty aggressively,
right? Like they were before. >> It's the It's the smears,
you guys. I I just like I I like I'm
look like they got more motion than they >> Okay, this
is this is where we're at. >> Unless I'm thinking of a
different pack. I think it was PV though. I think it was progressive
voice. >> Progen.
It's the It's the smears, you guys. I I just like I I like I'm
so flabbergasted that he was so egregious about these smears.
It's just full on slander. There's no way he believes this [__]
Actively farming the um Hassan talks too much about genocide
button like they were before cuz like there's obviously different
>> of course we're tying it to Gaza. Like of course of
course he's going to find some way to tie it to Gaza, right?
>> Forces that motivate these people. And one of them is
like organic audience development, right? They're content creators
first and foremost. They're mercenaries. They don't give a [__]
about politics. That's fine. >> He's saying that about
me. Like I'm just a mercenary. I don't give a >> I don't
think so. I don't I really don't think Man, I think Hassan's
like weaving here or Hold on. We We skipped past a little bit
of important context on >> like more misinformation right
there. Like Destiny was not a part of the founding of Progressive
Victory. My understanding is that like so Brianna Woo was a part
of Progressive Victory when it was first founded. There's a different
guy who heads up the whole operation named Sam. Uh but Destiny
was not a part of like the founding of Progressive Victory. My
understanding was that uh Vos was a really important part of
founding Progressive Victory, not Destiny. So, they're getting
these they're getting like basic facts like wrong. Like again,
this this had nothing like the pack had nothing to do with >> Am
I thinking of a different pack then? Because PV did reach out
to me quite a bit. I thought it was I thought they did. I think
they they wanted to work with me to like legitimize themselves
to the best of their ability. >> They wanted to work with
you to like help beat Republicans. So, yeah, of course you weren't
interested in that, >> Within the Democratic party,
>> what a great what a good nice touch. That's the wit.
That's that that's that sharp wit that we're we've come to expect
from this guy. Okay. Yeah, they wanted to beat Republicans. I
guess that wouldn't interest you, bro. >> Infrastructure
to make themselves look like they got more emotion than they
actually do. Unless I'm thinking of a different pack. I think
it was PV though. I think it was progressive
It's the It's the smears, you guys. I I just like I I like I'm
so flabbergasted that he was so egregious about these smears.
It's just full on slander. There's no way he believes this. >> Actively
farming the um Hassan talks too much about genocide button like
they were before cuz like there's obviously >> Of course,
we're tying it to Gaza. Like of course of course he's going to
find some way to tie to Gaza right forces that motivate these
people and one of them is like organic audience development right
they're content creator first and foremost they're mercenaries
they don't give a [__] about politics that's fine
he's saying that about me like I'm just a mercenary I don't give
a [__] about politics but like at least they have
to have some semblance some capacity >> I like here I think
he's still in the slot tubers I think this is him talking about
Willie Mack
and like people like that I think he's more Doro Willy Mack focused
even though he talked about progressive victory for a second
when he's talking about like slap tubers and this criticism that
like they don't do politics. That is like Willie Mack and Dioro.
That's who he's talking about. >> Read the room. And when
they read the room and they see that the room is yelling free
Palestine, [__] Israel over and over again at them.
They don't they can't hit that as hard as they once did cuz they
did do that for the past 22 months. They did that pretty aggressively,
right? Um and and even then they didn't want to do it by like
taking an open stance. They did it by just like attacking uh
people like myself, people like Froen, others who were actually
actively fundraising, actively criticizing Israel. just like
attacked all of the pro Palestine content creators they could
from other like drama related irrelevant >> like like and
I I don't know what he is ascribing to me as far as my motives
go. Why am I doing so he's saying I'm attacking pro Palestine
voices that are calling attention to a genocide like for for
what purpose now? Like why am I doing this? Like >> Mike
Gracie? I'm pretty sure that what he's talking about here is
in fact like the the Willy Mack durotype.
>> So So like he so now he's ting mentioned progressive
victory though. Like I guess he's legitimizing the idea that
we were being paid to like stifle any conversations about genocide
or something like that. Like points of
>> In a way for them to basically position themselves not
as like super pro-Israel. Uh so cuz you know you always need
a little bit of plausible deniability and you need to maintain
this like quote unquote aolitical attitude that you have over
this issue. >> No offense. This is just Hassan. I recognize
the talking points. Okay? I know where the talking points are
coming from. I'm telling you Hutch is
I wrote some of these talking points. I know where they come
from. Okay, I handed the copy over to Hassan's PA. I know where
these talking points come from. This is not about Hutch. >> For
what? Like, why would I benefit from this? What kind of an agenda
do I have to do something like this? What would be motivating
me to do that? Uh um but while simultaneously still doing it,
right? Simultaneously still uh attacking and positioning yourself
against those who are uh pro Palestine. So, they don't really
do that anymore. So, there's something else that needs to keep
motivating them. And I guess like you know being a part of Destiny's
orbit uh for a crumb of additional eyeballs that you might get
from his very loyal fandom, his very loyal community could be
one of those motivators. Uh another one is just like direct payments
that you can get from this like Destiny's friend slush fund.
So there right there, now you have it. There it is. He's accusing
me of taking money from Progressive Victory to not to explicitly
to uh like attack
profiles on creators that were trying to call attention to to
genocide. right there. He just accused me of taking money to
undermine pro Palestinian activists. This isn't based on anything.
It's just full-on malicious slander.
Like, can I sue this guy for real? Like, can I sue this guy?
That is an insane thing to say. And do you guys understand like
he has a massive audience, you guys? This particular vi only
has like 24,000 views. He was doing this whole speech and reacting
to this video when he had 30,000 viewers. And then those clips
make the rounds on the smaller leftist uh uh Twitter accounts,
you know, people like Gate Fumodor, whatever they like. So, like
he puts this stuff out there and then these little foot soldiers,
they go online and then they spread these lies and then I'm getting
[__] hundreds of people in my replies accusing me
of doing something that is like heinous. That is such a heinous
thing to accuse someone of to take money to cover for Israel.
That's like one of the like you understand that's like that's
one of the worst things that you could accuse a creator of doing.
And it's not based on anything. There's nothing to substantiate
the claim. I mean I if this isn't slander, I don't know what
it is. Like I you know this is a this is a new low for sure for
for Hassan to do stuff like this. Man, h I guess I just didn't
go back quite far enough.
I need to listen to a little more of this from the beginning
cuz he's saying like the Willy Mack talking points. Oh, they're
not committed to politics. They don't do any of this [__]
right? I just don't think that applies to Hutch directly. But
anything about it, you literally don't know any if I do that
same with the express purpose of getting a higher profile within
the DNC and push progressive voices out. This is Gremlow speaking
up in his chat who's another just Gremlow is a is a I don't know.
I feel like it's a bit Gremlow said, "I covered PB last year
and didn't get much coverage. Briana Woo set this up with Destiny
with the express purpose of getting him higher profile within
the DNC and push progressive voices out, yourself included."
Like, okay, I understand that they might not want to hear that.
To me, that was pretty much how it worked was they they were
sort of like, "Okay, we're going to we're going to cross-pollinate.
We already have progressives." Bana Woo went and hired like all
of the liberals around Destiny. I control F the transcript already.
It's >> then why >> there's a lot of hutch yapping
in between the contract people that were like there was um I
don't know if I can I don't know how much detail I can get into
it but within the creator program the work that we there were
there were like full-on communists in the program like communist
like Marxists. >> Yeah. Who came in before Brianna Woo.
Brianna Woo didn't hire those people on as far as I know >> except
maybe Vosch, but Vos was already partnered too. >> Was
set up between Briana Woo and Destiny with the express purpose
of getting him a higher profile within the DNC and pushing progressive
voices out, yourself included. Why did they collaborate with
Emma Vigand and Vos and Ryan Grim? >> Because that agenda
came about based on those meetings. Has he decided he couldn't
stomach these people based on those meetings? Getting like mobged
in person by Vos by Vos being a social butterfly who can get
along with everybody and Destiny like sat in the corner not being
able to talk to anyone. Like that's basically it's just entirely
spite driven. Yeah. >> If they were trying to push out
progressive voices doesn't make any sense. It is completely nonsensical.
Literally Bosch was and still is a part of PV. That's the other
thing too, bro. I mean like so to be clear that's that's more
that's like more misinformation right there. Like Destiny was
not a part of the founding of Progressive Victory. My understanding
is that like so Brianna Woo was a part of Progressive Victory
when it was first founded. There's a different guy who heads
up the whole >> This is wrong. Brianna Woo wasn't a part
of them when they were first founded. Bron Woo came in way after
they were founded. He just, by the way, he just accused Hassan
of lying based on getting something wrong like that, right? Or
maybe it was bad and panata where they were saying like Destiny
founded this or something. I think I think it was bad said Destiny
founded this and then Hassan corrected him, right? And now Hutch
is doing the same level of misinformation. Well, Brianna Woo
was there at the start, but then she wasn't. No, she wasn't there
at the start. Hutch,
like you just you do the same kinds of lies that are entirely
size side. Why? Why? And then you soy the out about them doing
it. What? Like in the segment where you soy about them doing
it, you do it. >> Operation named Sam. >> Okay. Anyway,
I'm I'm I'm done. I'm done with that. >> Called. So like
those are their two foundational principles. And so this kind
of combines both of those things. So like we're corruptly influenced
by
>> Wasn't that just a misspeak? Why would it be a misspeak?
He's he's doing like a timeline. The timeline was incorrect.
You could say it's just a misp, but then you'd have to give that
same charity to Hassan for anything he said just one time. I'm
saying that if you want to accuse other people of lying about
you, you should probably write some stuff down and make sure
that you're getting things accurately, right?
To be silent about a a genocide. And so I can't think of like
a there's only like there's only a few things that you could
be accused of in the space that would be worse than that. And
he just did it so casually based on nothing. >> Yeah. He's
conditioned his audience to kind of just uncritically accept
whatever he says. It's really helped him kind of skirt any criticism
and really just to level the most uh defamatory and just malicious
claims against his perceived political opponents. I mean, they
claim that I'm a Destiny Orbiter and I've never even spoken to
him. I don't even know the guy >> and I'm a Why we have
to Okay, I I don't know. People say Destiny Orbiter or something.
Okay. But I don't get why people act like having a direct tie
to somebody who is extremely closely tied to Destiny is like
confusing, right? Like somebody who openly still like chills
for this guy or was chilling for this guy. I just don't I don't
understand why that's We act like that's crazy to think there's
a connection >> Destiny Orbiter. Meanwhile, >> yeah.
Yeah. Like he's sponsored by Redact.dev. Does he know the the
history of this company? Does he know that this company only
exists because devs who were close to Destiny, who were in Destiny's
community, worked for slave wages for Dan? That's the only reason
this company exists. Does he know that? Is he >> got his
son on the record saying [__] like this? >> If
Destiny was my roommate, I get him laid all the time. >> I
mean, he Why is he trying to get that guy laid? That's the last
thing that guy >> I wanted to say that what you said. >> Does
Hassan even know any kids to introduce Destiny to? Like, why
would Hassan say that? That really resonates with me, too, because
before all of this, like people would call me ugly, a skeleton,
whatever. I could handle that. I had no problem with those things.
It was funny to me. But nowadays, it's resorted to like calling
me a terrorist,
uh, a valley target,
>> A baby killer.
>> Slave wages. Lauo, >> go talk to Dan about this.
Dan brags about paying people pennies. Dan brags about paying
them slave wages. Dan is psyched to pay them slave wages. I You
think I'm making this up? This is just stuff Dan openly says
and is like gleeful about all the time. >> And it all originated
from us just not fully agreeing to the 1,000% on all >> And
I didn't touch it with a 10ft pole because that I I'm sorry I'm
beating a dead horse because I know I've talked about this a
lot on the stream, but that to me it's still mind-blowing to
me that that is what kicked off the whole schism between Hassan
and Ethan. which I think a lot of us saw coming like a mile away.
Uh
cuz October 7th happens
and Hassan had the reaction that he did which was to say that
October 7th was imperfect resistance. He didn't he didn't want
to concede. He didn't want to give any ground. You know, he made
no effort to uh like meaningfully
>> Wait, I don't think he said it was a perfect resistance.
Do we really have to do this every time?
>> Which was to say that October 7th was imperfect resistance.
>> Imperfect resistance. Okay. No, no, no. Wasn't he he
didn't say ah perfect like Okay. imperfect resistance. It was
imperfect resistance.
Obviously, >> he didn't he didn't want to conceully
address the like barbarity of the violence on October 7th. And
even then, like I felt like Assan was or Ethan was willing to
meet him in the middle because they did their podcast shortly
after and it was really emotionally charged podcast and uh it
was very shortly after October 7th and yet e Ethan was still
in my mind like crying sincere tears think invoking the image
of a Palestinian
holding their dead kid. And so very shortly after October 7th,
Ethan was was more than will Okay, hold on. We've got uh one
more thing here on this. This is uh Hutch arguing in some Ogre
boy mentions. Okay. With Kilo actually. So I'm not going to watch
this whole clip cuz I honestly
>> they're helping
>> I'm not going to watch the whole thing unfortunately.
But Hutch comes in. He says this is a bit silly. No. By the time
Ethan and I had this discussion, the cat was out of the bag and
the harassment campaign was already in full swing. My mentions
are filled with people accusing me of being a paid Israeli camp
propagandist. That's this happened because Hassan platformed
and agreed with bad empanadas insane claims. Do you think there
was an appropriate behavior? Do you think that was appropriate
behavior by Hassan? Is there nothing there worth condemning between
the PII and the completely basis allegations? If your answer
is no, I don't know what to say. Tribalism is a hell of a drug.
Gila responds, "What is the claim you object to Hassan making?"
Here he pushes back on some of the what bad empanada is saying.
It seems like his main criti criticisms were it was a fund that
was supporting people who were Destiny's friends and who do Israel
pro-Israel propaganda
>> to do Zionist propaganda and to kiss the ring regarding
like destiny and >> I don't I don't think it's like I mean
this is like bad empanada's like drama side muddying the waters
a little bit cuz like it's not just about that that is a function
of it for sure but >> so when Hassan says that when he
says function he I think he means Like that is what happens,
right? That is what happens is you end up paying people to do
when you pay the bit when you have when you're involved with
and pay the friends of the biggest Israel propagandist like Zionist
propagandist then you do end up doing that. It's not just that,
right? Like they probably did cuz I I remember
they were doing like activations with like politicians and [__]
right? Like like real politicians, not just like specifically
using it uh to to do uh Zionist propaganda. Just shut up to do
Okay. Do you even understand what you're posting here? He's saying
PB wasn't exclusively a Destiny/ fund to pay influencers to do
Zionist propaganda because they also did activations. He's agreeing
with bada's claims and saying but they did other stuff too. Do
you think it's appropriate or responsible for someone like Hassan
to make such insane and baseless
And then Kilo says yes. He's pushing back on the presentation
that PB itself was some sort of Zionist entity and that what
exactly is defamatory but the counter claim that in function
it worked as a Destiny and co-paid fund that paid Zionist influencers.
Besides the fact, so I think this is like a reasonable question.
So besides the fact that none of that is true, and there's zero
evidence for this, besides the fact that the program included
many creators that were super critical of Israel, honestly, it
might have been most of the creators, the cover you guys run
for this guy is wild. He absolutely did not push back on PV being
a Zionist pack. He agrees with Badam Panat at the end of the
video that the pack was paying creators to do Israeli propaganda.
Okay, so he links this video. Please don't link just the full
video. >> I mean, that's where I was, isn't it? He doesn't
like the time stamp at all. He doesn't like a time stamp at all.
So Hutch, dude, god damn it. >> Clear. That's that's more
that's like more misinformation right there. Like Destiny was
not a part of the founding
>> Progressive Victory. My understanding is that like so
Brian Woo was a part of Progressive Victory when it was first
>> 3806. So the the first thing here is he's talking about
the people who only criticize Palestinian voices and that in
effect that turns into like pro genocide speech or something.
It's so easy to time stamp videos. I just wanted like the part
where he is explicitly saying this cuz there was a part and I
want to listen to it again cuz now I feel like I've got most
of the context
and when they read the room and they see that the room is yelling
free Palestine Israel over and over again at them, they don't
they can't hit that as hard as they once did cuz they did do
that for the past 22 months. They did that pretty aggressively,
right? Um and and even then they didn't want to do it by like
taking a an open stance. They did it by just like attacking
uh people like myself, people like Frogan, uh others who were
actually actively fundraising, actively criticizing Israel. They
just like attacked uh all of the pro Palestine content creators
they could from other like drama related irrelevant like like
and I I don't know what he is ascribing to me as far as my motives
go. Why am I doing so? He's saying I'm attacking pro Palestine
voices that are calling attention to a genocide. Like for for
for what purpose now? Like why am I doing this? Like so it's
so like he so now he's tying it to like the propaganda thing.
Like I guess he's legitimizing the idea that we were being paid
to like stifle any conversations about genocide or something
like that. Like points of slander in a way for them to basically
position themselves not as like super pro-Israel. Uh so cuz you
know you always need a little bit of plausible deniability and
you need to maintain this like quote unquote apolitical
uh attitude that you have over this issue
>> for what like why would I >> yeah Hassan is like
I'm sorry I'm just watching he's like it's like he's took somebody's
homework and he's one to one repeating like talking points we've
done on this stream multiple times right about how
I'm going to say these ones are like the queen talking points
pretty explicitly okay pretty explicitly The Willie Mack doesn't
have an actual political opinion. Neither does Yorio. They don't
actually they don't actually describe the political situation.
They don't have any nuance or understanding of it. They just
attack people because they know there's an audience there, right?
Like he's just explicitly doing those exact talking points. And
Hush doesn't understand that that doesn't apply to him. But I
think because it's sandwiched in with some PV stuff, I can see
how uh I can see how he gets here, how he's like confused. Uh
I think there's a different way this works. Pizza philosophy.
I think basically there's a different way this work this works.
He said truth nuke on his stream today. I swear to God he watches
Queman's stream sometimes. Truth nuke is a thing Queman says.
Listen, there's obviously like a cabal there where like information
flows between these different groups. Okay. Apparently, I'll
tell you what it actually is, okay?
When when someone goes live and says Hutch is a liar and he won't
respond to any of this because he's so disingenuous. He just
like totally websiticisms in with groups he doesn't want to interact
with because he wants to avoid all criticism and he's a [__]
Hutch is a [__] Right? When people go live and do
that and Hutch runs away. Hutch just runs away. He runs away
every time. Right. Eventually people see that and they go, "Oh
well, I guess that must be what I should say." Hutch also lied
about Yeah, sure. Sure, sure. Matt Slice, I feel like he did
that. Yeah, I feel like we went and looked that up, right? We
went and looked at the Piers interview. Watch it again. benefit
from this?
What kind of an agenda do I have to do something like this? >> Yeah.
Old man yells at Cloud. This is not about him,
unfortunately. >> Willing and and inclined
to express deep sympathy for Palestinians in Gaza that >> Oh,
wait, wait, wait. I wanted to finish the tweet thread real quick.
So, besides the fact that none of this is true, you guys run
for this guy's wild. He links the video. Pave has gone through
several iterations, both in terms of who it paid and how it functioned.
I think the period of interest here is from around the time Brianna
Woo was brought on as creator leazison and the months following
which over overlapped at the start of the conflict in Gaza. Are
you prepared to make the claim that most of the creators involved
with PV during this time were not Destiny orbiters and were not
Zionists? Oh, Kilo up here a little bit. Most of the creators
brought on during this time is what you should have said.
Okay,
Kilo, you should have said most of the creators brought on during
this time were not Zionists. Cuz I think they kept all of those
all those progressive people. I think they just kept paying them
the whole time. I don't think they took any of them off of the
payroll. I think they just kept paying them for nothing.
Anyway, bud, for real, why is it difficult to acknowledge that
a creator like you uh like a creator you like made an insane
accusation? You do not actually have to do the it's always sunny
conspiracy board in an attempt to legitimize what are obviously
malicious lies.
Bro, I could just walk him through this really easily. I don't
watch this on you're teasing threatening him with a defamation
lawsuit. He said that PV functioned as a destiny slush fund that
spread pro-Israel propaganda, which by my account uh of the time
period that he's referring to is demonstrabably true. I didn't
mean to say demonstrabably here. I meant plausibly. Oh, sure.
We get a response from Hutch. We do. Do you ever hear Do you
even hear yourself? List all of the creators in their media program.
All the PV staff that worked with creators. Wait, no. Just do
the ones in their media program. The rest of the staff and what
events they organized, who they canvas for. Outline what creator
program actually did. The creator program actually did. You can't
the Sissant's claim. Wait, hold on. We know a lot of this. We
know a whole heck of a lot of this. Like,
this is crazy to me. Okay, because I think you can I think this
stuff is there in the filings. I think you can go see who they
were paying around this time. What was PV's primary function?
Would you say if you had to paraphrase their mission statement?
Just want to be clear, no sidesteping. You actually have no idea
about the full scope of who was a part of PV and what they actually
did. Correct. I probably have a greater understanding of this
than almost anybody outside of the people who are in the organization.
There's no way this is true given your takes in this thread.
You have no idea what you're what it was actually doing. Trying
to be reasonable here. I feel you have a tendency to bring up
people's basis of knowledge or who they might be watch who they
might watch or be influenced by as a standin for responding to
what's actually being said. Why does it matter whether or not
I have intimate knowledge of the inner workings of the structure
of PV? Does that have anything to do with the claim that they
were paying a significant number of Destiny orbiters and Zionists?
Dude, the claim from Be and Hassan is that PV was a Destiny Orbiter
slush fund and that we were being paid to spread propaganda.
No, they said that he said that was the effect of what happened.
You said this sounded plausible that that you could see that
effect that functionally you could you could operate that way.
That could be your function like an entailment of paying Destiny
and a bunch of his friends that you end up paying Zionist influencers.
That's totally plausible. The reason I'm pointing out your lack
of understanding of PV was that what they were and what they
were doing is because it's relevant to my point. These claims
are utterly baseless. Nothing we did ever had to do with Israel
or Destiny. Here, let me blow it up for you. Why was Lyken involved?
Seems like a pretty weird addition given his Israel takes. And
what evidence is there that people who are pushing pro-Israel
talking points in order to curry favor with Destiny to begin
with? Like, what the even is that proposition? Lol. He was f
he was friends with people who were super anti-Israel, including
Lyken.
Sure.
But I don't know. Was like was Lykan really paid as a media influencer?
I actually don't know. Pey had nothing to do Well, that's what
Hutch is saying. PV had nothing to do with Destiny. Are you guys
seriously suggesting that people that people felt pressure or
some kind of incentive to be pro-Israel? There is zero evidence
of this happening. Another issue is what you guys consider pro
Israel. What you actually what you actually mean by that is people
who don't, agree with you on every one of your positions on the
matter. So, he's just treating Kilo like a progressive, like
a hardcore lefty. And that's not who Kilo is. Kila is just the
guy who made the video on Progressive Victory, right? That he
thought there was like weirdness with the lack of disclosures
and so he looked into it. I don't know why we have to pretend
like he's a Hassan fan. My music stopped. What the [__]
What a what a Okay. Never been a staunch Israel supporter. I've
never in my life been a staunch Israel supporter. I'll be honest
with you. There's like 12 layers of confusion here that I'm not
really sure how to properly untangle. Let me simplify this and
ask, do you think you're not Do you not think you're a propagandist?
Uhoh. That was a weird way to engage with that. That was never
going to work. Is this you, Max?
Max, dude. Out of nowhere, Max comes in and drops Hutch as like
an IDF. That's a funny tweet. This you, man. I hope you're happy,
Max. You made Hutch stop engaging with Kilo? I would love to
respond to some of the stuff Hutch said. Okay, but unfortunately,
based on not engaging with him basically at all, Hutch blocked
me. I don't understand why. I don't know how I got blocked. I
didn't do anything.
Well, sorry. I did I did use a like voice for him multiple times
on stream. I did make him sound like a complete on stream, but
that would imply that he see my stream or stream clips for some
reason and then decided to block me on Twitter, which would just
be weird. Yeah, I'm like preemptively blocked. I don't understand
how I got preemptively blocked cuz I don't even participate in
a bunch of this here. Check DMs for what? Yeah, I see that. Anyway,
I don't know how much more I had on Hutch for this this stream.
It Oh, what was this? Ethan and Hutch. This is a Uhoh. >> What
did you do with the >> Is this Is this a Snark subreddit?
I think this might be a Snark subreddit. Hold on. Ethan and Hutch
are lying, deliberately misrepresenting Hassan's position on
the Progressive Victory Pack. They're portraying it as if Hassan
was calling it a Zionist entity with the sole goal to spread
propaganda. Hassan said it's not just about >> So, what
did you do with that a week before this new video released? Sure.
He said it's not just about that, but he said functional. That's
like how it functions, right? Is which is an understandable point.
Okay, you're going to pay Destiny his friends. I don't even think
it's correct by the way. >> So, victory. >> It's
basically just a pack to promote uh progressive policies and
candidates all over the country. >> Uh this is not what
it was. He blocked Queman way before he blocked me. This is not
what it was. >> So, they did uh camping events for like
Andy Kim in New Jersey. I think they did one for Kl Harris, Wisconsin.
I was there. We weren't paid to be at that camping event, but
they also did one for Jamal Bowman. So, like he is a very outspoken
anti-Israel critic. Uh so the idea that progressive victory was
some Zionist entity. >> You watch Queenman's Wait, how
do you know he watched Queensman's react to the chorus panel
like that it just crumbles when you point to a couple different
things, you know, they approached Tassant to work with him? Why
are they doing that? Froen helped them organize an event to get
out the
big Ryan Grim
>> Yeah, this is I think this was quite a bit before. So
I'm I'm fuzzy on the timeline with that and then when they started
hiring the influencers around Destiny. I think they started hiring
influencers around Destiny before that and like you could argue
is more around Twitch pole and it just in effect like kind of
ended up being attached to Destiny, right? But it's like about
how it looks to other people. Most people know Destiny. They
know those people through Destiny if they know them at all. So,
so like it might not have been an overt thing where they were
hiring just Destiny's friends. They might have started with like
Wick and Counterpoints and a couple people from Twitch and then
that like Brianna Woo wise cuz Brianna Woo doesn't really have
friends and she wanted to pay people to be her friend. So, she
started with those people, right? She had already kind of known
Wick a little bit. I could see it working out that way, you know.
>> So, either is lying or, you know, he's accusing all,
you know, all of his friends or whoever else of working with
a Zionist pack. Like, you can only have one of those two things.
You can have >> Some of these Zistubers who have covered
on this channel have been paid by Zionist organizations for quote
unquote advertising services. >> Here's what let's pull
up the song's video. Let me play this >> is is because
uh it's already public
>> for they distributed a handsome $1.2 million to themselves
and people associated with them basically for two things. to
do Zionist propaganda and to >> okay all right >> kiss
the ring regarding like destiny and >> I don't >> uh
manite pixie and supreme worked for PV2 yeah but they all worked
as people who were non um what do you call it like they weren't
media personalities for PB they were like background they like
helped set up events 850k went to FFAC yeah I didn't think it
was millions of dollars on anything they were doing like anything
they had to do with uh creators and [__] anyway I'd
say that's about it for that I might switch over. Let's see.
How long do we have on the stream? Maybe we need one more hour
here. How long do I need to do this? We got an hour. Okay. I
kind of wanted to do I might do a little drama here. Okay. I
think that's enough for the Hutch stuff. I just I think this
guy's like really imprecise with the way he speaks and it's just
like it's kind of annoying when he I don't think he's significantly
I'm sure Hutch could be good on issues when he like looks into
issues and he like figures out but on
I feel like when he gets into the side stuff it's like the sides
stuff it's just he's going to go Hassan is bad and not really
engage.